the work is hard even though she's done
it for years rosemary was a chambermaid
in an apartment in Barcelona until about
six months ago she developed tendinitis
in her right arm and went on sick leave
the mother of four says her job caused
the injury I have trouble lifting things
making beds cleaning setting tables the
constant up and down motion there comes
a point where my arm just can't lift
anymore
chamber maids like Rosemary say working
conditions in the hotel sector are tough
despite Spain's booming tourist industry
last year ninety-three million guests
paid decent money for overnight stays
and a new record is expected for this
year
Maria recently left her former job as a
chambermaid because of the working
conditions she prefers to remain
anonymous but says it's much better now
compared to her old workplace there we
only had between seven and ten minutes
for each room we weren't allowed to take
breaks or eat lunch and instead of
ending our shift at 5:00 we had to do
one paid extra work afterwards they
never paid for overtime our emotional
rosemary was fired for taking too much
sick leave but she says she worked for a
whole year despite her impairment he's a
poor I want that maybe because I kept
working despite the pain my arm never
had a chance to rest and recover so I
wasn't able to do the work as expected
but still I worked hard and did
everything I could
so I leave with my head held high
for whatever
now rosemarys among the 20% of Spaniards
out of work the hotel says it acted
lawfully four years ago a labor market
reform made it easier for companies to
fire employees even those who are ill
the hotel director says competition is
fierce company is not a charitable
organization there are investors who
risk their money and want to make a
profit otherwise they wouldn't invest
their money so we have to make decisions
accordingly
sometimes they're pleasant sometimes
they're not so there's some we establish
the union's say the labor market reform
is to blame for this situation during
the economic crisis the government
pushed through the reform in spite of
opposition from labor representatives
before the reform it was illegal to fire
employees from one day to the next and
then hire them to work for half the pay
through a temp agency rather than hire
them directly through the hotel the
chambermaids are disappointed that the
unions fail to prevent the labor market
reform they founded an organization
called las calles to put pressure on
hotels and temp organizations they want
certain physical conditions to be
recognized as occupational illnesses if
this were so rosemary might get some
support cuando salad mi pie when I came
here from Bolivia I never thought it
would come to this it pains me that I
cannot provide for my children as I want
to
there are some 100,000 chambermaids
working in Spain but they're not well
organized politically and when they go
on strike they're easily replaced by the
hotels because there are so many others
desperate for work